Monday morning today is the first day of
Kwanzaa the week-long holiday a
celebration of African-American culture
and tonight the West Las Vegas Library
and the historic west side is holding a
beginner's guide on Kwanzaa Candace
Charles is there live this morning with
the meeting behind the holiday Candace
good morning to you
good morning John good morning folks yes
the week-long events starts tonight with
a marketplace right here in the library
huge celebration and China Hudson has
been helping put this together for a
number of years since a lot of people
come out for this event tell us a little
bit about what Kwanzaa is all about
Kwanza is about family community and
culture it's an African-American holiday
where it celebrates Unity Community
culture food family it's a wonderful
time of year and we just love putting on
the festivities here at the West Las
Vegas Library theater amazing and boba
tea right there in the back is drumming
for us right now he's one of 10 vendors
will be at the marketplace you'll have
Emmy award-winning Storyteller Ina the
sunshine Storyteller here tonight on the
stage as well tell us a little bit about
what else is going on tonight so at five
o'clock if you need to know anything
about Kwanzaa you want to come to quanta
101 at 6 PM we have Sunshine the
Storyteller so please please please
bring the children so they can hear some
African stories right after the sunshine
Storyteller we're going to do a
community tribute to one of our heroes
and then we're going to close it out
with olabisi African dance and drum
Ensemble so we're going to have African
dancing and drama it's going to be a
fabulous time here at the library
amazing and each day of Kwanzaa really
means something special and different
what do you hope that people take away
from the week of events here because
they'll also be an event on Wednesday
coming any of it on Friday but the week
of events here and really from the whole
week of Celebration I really want people
to understand that Kwanzaa has
absolutely nothing to do with religion
and everything to do about family
community and culture and I just want
the richness of who we are as
African-American people to be filled in
the building for the next week so
hopefully everyone will come out and
starting tonight at five o'clock for
Kwanzaa 101. amazing thank you Shannon
and thank you brother T so much for
joining us this morning for all that
you're doing for the community really is
amazing you can find out more details on
our website 8newsnow.com again it all
kicks off tonight at 5 pm at the West
Las Vegas Library for now live from the
West Las Vegas Library I'm Candace
Charles 8 News Now